and we are tracking the very latest
developments from the 2020 election both
here in our state
and all across the country thanks for
being with us here at noon everyone i'm
alex backus i'm john langler so this
morning clark county released new
numbers and gave an update and during
the update it said it'll give another
one this afternoon
here are the latest results from clark
county and from the state of nevada
presidential results you can see there
joe biden is leading barely you can see
there by 50 percent of the vote right
now
there are the numbers specific to clark
county again
former vice president joe biden leading
president trump with 54 percent of the
vote
in district 4 democrat stephen horsford
has just announced
he is claiming victory and has been
declared the winner in his race for
congressional district 4 beating
jim marchand alex well let's turn to
state senate district
six now and nicole cannazzaro is now
ahead of april becker you can see the
results there although it is very very
close
essentially 50 both ways and county
commission district
c that is still neck and neck as well so
we're still watching
those races this noon hour